على مقياس من واحد إلى عشرة ، ما مدى
قلقك بشأن انتشار جدري
القردة في الولايات المتحدة ، هل أنت قلق أكثر من
عام مضى قبل
شهر وليس قبل
شهر في اليوم السابق حيث يجب
أن نشعر بالقلق تمامًا بنسبة 100 بالمائة  اه قلق
لأننا لم نصاب بجدري القرود بالطريقة
التي رأيناها الآن ولا نريده
أن يصبح جزءًا من الحياة بالطريقة التي
نراها ولذا علينا أن نبقى في طليعة
الأمر وهذا ما
لقد حاولنا القيام بذلك منذ اليوم الأول ، لقد قمنا الآن
بزيادة عدد اللقاحات المتوفرة لدينا
كما ذكرت
أن لدينا حوالي 3000 حالة تم
الإبلاغ عنها ، ونعتقد أن هناك عدة
أكثر من ذلك بكثير ، لكننا لدينا  حصلنا على حوالي
300000 لقاح زائد قمنا بتوفيره الآن في
جميع أنحاء البلاد جيدًا
نقطتان قمت بتوضيحهما
أولاً وقبل كل شيء على مقياس من واحد إلى عشرة ما
مدى قلقك اليوم
أه يبدو دائمًا مهتمًا
بشيء قادم  لم يكن علينا
التعامل مع ذلك قبل العاشرة بل هو كذلك
لديك
نعم لأننا نريد أن نتقدم عليه ،
فأنت لا تريده أن يصبح جزءًا من
الحياة ،
لكن كم عدد الأشخاص الذين ماتوا مقارنة
بـ covet
zero
أنا أفهم ذلك ولكنه
مصدر قلق كبير لأولئك الأشخاص المتأثرين
وهؤلاء الأشخاص الذين تعرضوا لك قلت  نشك في وجود
العديد من الحالات أكثر من 3000 حالة تم
الإبلاغ عنها الآن
كم عدد المضاعفات التي تتحدث عنها ،
وهذا صعب هو أننا نحتاج إلى
الولايات التي يقدمها مديرو الصحة العامة المحليون
إلينا لتزويدنا بالبيانات حتى لا نعرف فقط حتى
يكون لدينا إحساس بماذا
نوع الحجم الذي نتحدث عنه ولكن
لمعرفة أفضل طريقة لتركيز المساعدة
التي يمكننا تقديمها